after two decades of addiction Darius
dumo is seeking help to overcome habit
he says he cultivated during liberan
Civil War I was at the age of 14 years
old when I joined the revolution so I
started first day I started smoking the
thing they call marijuana grass you
understand so started smoking the grass
we smoke the grass and know the grass no
longer make you feel the way you a what
you want to feel feel like so how I get
into the drugs according to United
Nations figures an estimated 133% of
Liberia's population is abusing drugs it
says 20% of young people are also
addicted to illicit
substances with the absence of a proper
government program to tackle the problem
individuals and non-governmental
organizations are stepping in after the
detox which has to do with the
medications and all that after after
that we get into more counseling and
trying to provide some um vocational
training skills for them our institution
can only help a few addicts at a time
and they are mostly kept for a maximum
of 3
months but 40% of rehabilitated addicts
she says fall back into the Habit
because drugs are cheap and easily
available on the
streets drug Cutters are increasingly
targeting West Africa because of weak
law enforcement but Liberian security
official Hope Community engagement will
help to curb the rise in smuggling and
use of hard drugs and we have
confiscated lot of drugs even the M talk
about $100 million of drugs we he
confiscated that drugs though the case
in court it went the way we least
expected but however that is a c system
Liberia recently passed a New Drug law
but many here tell us that corruption
won't allow it to
succeed Darius says he's now recovered
but there are signs he's still
struggling but at least for now he's
found a temporary job at the rehab
center ahammed rris Al jaer morovia